the Medicare annual enrollment period is
happening now in Select Health the
sponsors of this next segment are
hosting a phone bank tomorrow here to
tell us more is Grayson Howard a Select
Health Medicare sales manager welcome
Grayson hey thank you for having me so
who is Select Health so Select Health we
are an integrated health system with IHC
down here Intermountain Healthcare in
Nevada and we're helping the members
live their healthiest lives possible and
so we specialize in health care plans
and and right now we're here to talk
about the Medicare for Select Health so
because open enrollment is happening
right now so what is the open enrollment
period what goes down during open so
October 15th to December 7th is open
enrollment period so anybody who is
eligible for Medicare can enroll in
whatever plan fits their needs so that's
from October 15 to December 7th and what
should they be looking at when it comes
to selecting a new program or switching
things what worked last year or maybe
their lifestyle has changed what should
they be looking at when it comes to the
different plans right right so
everybody's needs change throughout the
year and so every year they get an
opportunity during those months or those
weeks through October through December
to look and see what fits their needs
now so every carrier has benefits they
have different uh hospitals that are in
network so every member needs to look
and make sure that the the plan that
they're on fits them best for what they
need and what are some some of the
different options that the plans have
because there's some that offer better
subscription or some that maybe there's
a benefit if you live a healthier
lifestyle you're more active so a lot of
plans offer a little a lot of different
ancillary benefits so Dental is a big
one a lot of plans offer gym memberships
so you can go to different facilities
the Select Health Plan actually offers
like golfing really yeah so golfing uh
there's not probably very much skiing in
Las Vegas
sure absolutely yep so they offer a lot
of different plans but you need to look
at it and just ask your agent that you
know and they would they'd be able to
walk you through that let's talk about
what's happening tomorrow because this
is a great segue because someone
probably watching right now has a lot of
questions we have a phone bank taking
place tomorrow from three to seven
what's happening tomorrow with the phone
bank so we'll have a Medicare answer
team that will be here to answer all
your Medicare questions so
um from three to seven they can call in
they can ask questions about the plan
asks what may be different from their
current plan or ask about their current
plan and see what changes have been made
to their current plan so we'll be here
to assist them with all their Medicare
needs for them and kind of guide them to
a plan that might suit their needs how
things made a change over the past year
it's great and we've got people here
answering all the questions you're very
informative I know people watching right
now have questions yes and they can call
tomorrow from three to seven there's
something I want to ask you about
because this is really cool the five
star rating that you guys got you're not
one to brag but I want you to brag tell
us more about this five star so five
star rating we're judged on how well we
do from a one to five scale five star is
the highest the best you can get Select
Health Has It Go on second year in a row
that's great so yep so second year in a
row uh do the five star plan we we get
that we're the only one in Utah Idaho
and Nevada that have the five-star plan
and so it's a big deal for us it's a big
deal for our members and it allows us to
enroll people all all year long due to
the five-star plan I love it Grace and
thank you so much for joining us we have
that phone bank taking place tomorrow
and then Select Health we need to reach
them here in town 1980 Festival Plaza
Drive Suite 9 30. you can call them at
1-855-442-9940 again Select Health
medicare.org and that full make is
happening tomorrow